I once again cannot believe that we have
to do this again but Donald Trump still
doesn't understand how this virus or
viruses in general spread
he doesn't understand contagion he
doesn't understand communal communicable
disease I don't know if you've heard
this but the White House is increasingly
overrun with coronavirus infections
Trump is reportedly furious people are
having to quarantine one of Mike Pence's
staffers his press secretary Katie
Miller she happens to be the wife of
Trump advisor Stephen Miller a sick sick
guy more nepotism anywhere you look you
look under a rock you look behind a
curtain at the White House it's nepotism
she has tested positive for coronavirus
one of trumps valets these are navy
people who are essentially purse a very
close personal assistance to the
president they handle his meals and that
type of thing
one of trumps valets has tested positive
for coronavirus Ivanka Trump's assistant
has the coronavirus why you know she
even has any role in what's going on at
the White House is another question but
she does and her assistant has tested
positive dr. Anthony foul she is now in
a modified self quarantine along with
dr. Redfield of the CDC because they
were exposed to people who tested
positive and Donald Trump doesn't get it
how could Katie Miller have the virus
she was previously tested and she was
negative she was tested again and she
was negative now all of a sudden she
tests positive how does that work it
makes no sense to Donald Trump look at
this tragic video this is maybe the
dumbest thing that Donald Trump has said
in his presidency maybe I mean it's up
there it's in the top 10 certainly take
a look yeah well I don't know much about
it does anybody want to talk about it it
she's a wonderful young woman Katie she
tested very good for a long period of
time and then all of a sudden today she
tested positive she hasn't come into
contact with me spend some time with the
vice president
it's I believe the press person right
say press person so she tested positive
out of the blue she tested very good for
a long period of time then all of a
sudden she tested positive today I guess
for some reason she tested positive
out of the blue that's how it works at
some point everyone on earth was
negative for coronavirus at some point
out of the blue I guess to use Trump's
phrase people started testing positive
who previously would have tested
negative if they had been given a test
guys he still doesn't understand it he
still doesn't get it he's visibly
confused by an even more catastrophic is
that Trump then uses this as a
justification to say tests aren't that
important
someone can test negative and then test
positive tests don't really matter that
much
that's Trump's conclusion from all of
this take a look this is why the whole
concept of tests aren't necessarily
great the tests are perfect but
something can happen between a test
where it's good and then something
happens and all of a sudden she was
tested very recently and tested negative
and then today I guess for some reason
she tested positive so mike knows about
it and mike has done what he has to do
something can happen between tests yeah
it's called catching the virus from
someone else that's how a virus works he
actually says people test negative and
then they test positive this is why I'm
saying testing isn't that important no
that's why testing is important and huge
amounts of testing are necessary levels
of testing that we are nowhere close to
there is no worse person to be dealing
with this crisis there is no worse or
more incompetent administration to have
in power during a global pandemic than
this administration we're trying to
scale up testing we're trying to
evaluate reopening strategies we're
trying to explore the connection between
you know vitamin D and the virus heat
and humidity and the viral the stuff
Trump wonders aloud about bleach
injections and still doesn't understand
how a virus works
when he says I don't get it she was
negative then she's positive it's almost
like he sees coronavirus as a hereditary
thing listen she tested for having type
A blood for years all of a sudden she
tests for type B blood it's really weird
how could that change right that's not
what this is she was born Asian and now
she tested black that's really weird I
thought people's race day no this is a
virus this is how it works this is how
people catch it and this is at this
point I think it was Bill Maher who said
on his Friday program lethal
incompetence lethal incompetence that's
what we're dealing with and my biggest
fear and I you know when we talk about
20/20 I try to keep it to just the facts
Biden's better on climate Biden's better
on judges Biden's better on taxes
Biden's better on healthcare
Biden's better on capital gay right just
we've got it we've got an option these
are the two options we've got to choose
everybody's got a vote but I do fear
that the guy's gonna get reelected
I know that the polls are looking pretty
good for Biden this guy has figured out
a way you know he lost the popular vote
by three million and seventy thousand
votes in three states combined with who
knows how many other X factors that
we've talked about suppression Russia
etc etc Comey coming out and talking
about Hillary unnecessarily a second
time any one of those things could have
pushed him over but 70,000 votes in
three states he won the electoral vote
I fear that once again he'll get lucky
and there will be a decline in the virus
just before wave 2 and it'll time right
out in early October with people saying
hey you know what we got past it even
though it took longer even though more
people died he got us past it and
they're gonna go out and vote for him
and I'm worried we're gonna have another
four years of this and it is lethal
incompetence as Bill Maher said let's
work really hard to make sure that
doesn't happen particularly as you see
what's going on with federal and Supreme
Court judges this is urgent and when it
happens over four years and the country
is still here we might feel like ads not
that bad no it's
very bad and the death toll is going to
be much higher in the United States than
it needed to be the economy is going to
suffer much worse and far longer than it
needed to suffer thanks to this and
we've got to all keep our eye on the
ball and not forget that in
five-and-a-half months we have an
opportunity to change who is in charge
we can change who will be in charge for
wave two and possibly wave three of this
and we've got to do that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep and it's a
sponsor I'm thrilled about because I
sleep on a helix mattress at home and
it's just the perfect mattress one of
the best things about helix is you don't
have to guess which mattress do I need
which one will be good for me you take
their famous sleep quiz on their website
you tell them your body type your
sleeping position your back pain issues
you might have and they will pair you
with a mattress that will be perfect for
you I took the sleep quiz the mattress
they suggested was exactly what I needed
I often get too hot at night the
mattress keeps me cool it's not too soft
it's not too firm the texture is right
and I've just been getting way better
sleep you only buy a mattress every
decade or so don't get stuck with
something that's not perfect for you and
all helix mattresses come with a 10 year
warranty and they'll even come to your
house and pick it up within a hundred
days if you don't love it but I think
you will all of my viewers will get up
to two hundred dollars off your order
and you'll get two super premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video